Identification.
Station nine recorded with faith and love and care
and cry on Tuesday the fifth of August one thousand nine hundred seven and identification. Identification.
This is Station. Eight.
Karen Craig speaking to faith based band
and it's recorded on Tuesday the fifth of August one thousand nine hundred seventy tape coming up.
So we went back to Germany. And I made for we left and I didn't know that he concentration care.
That was when the Germans went into you know. And persecuted the Jews.
And I just want to linger on that because that persecution of the very nice. People. Was so degrading to their.
To kneel on the streets scrap the streets. When the Nazis went to the university to throw the Jews out of the window.
And that's when Hunt's was arrested and put into trying to duck. Now.
So you see now I had met and it was at a time when a Shiite he was not speaking about that terrible period
but it came to me through another Viennese person.
Lily will use that hunting pain in the dark how concentration camp the name of the concentration.
Came to mean to me that.
We were more familiar with the big names of the big Europe black belts and so on but so too much.
Trying to think of the city which was I mean I think it was I have to check this on the get close.
I think it was in Mannheim own unique one of the other which wasn't so far from the dock.
And it's strange that when we hear that you automatically think of a concentration camp.
We tend to forget that it was a town where ordinary people like us lived and.
That these ordinary people close their eyes to what was going on.
In the big it was one of the biggest camps in fact in Europe. And so we got in the car and we drove to.
Do small and cold. And there was still.
And also the way because towards the end of the war they were burning the party where guns were traveling to the
concentration camps for those killed because they couldn't cope with the date and that you
and anyone you know just said they'd been the way. And the way. And there was also the hanging tree.
The train with people. Punishment and this place. Had been converted into a misplaced persons camp.
And so missed placed people from Eastern Europe and many of whom prefer to go and live in these camps and to be true.
And so we went. Where the people were living. There was no heating of any of the lighting.
People were making time a little far. Clicked around the place. And we spoke to a woman who was from.
Poland and she was with three children living in. And she.
But we have nothing virtually nothing and the people who were in these camps.
It was that they couldn't suffer any more. And the fact that thousands have just been living just a few years ago.
Before they. Didn't have any effect. Because they were too.
They had to be fully occupied with looking after their own life there. And that was a battle.
Well the Americans and the British. At that time and America.
Still grateful that the American Western Germany because they gained.
Food and they treated the Germans badly enough that we could muster any sympathy at that time but.
Throw them stuff truckloads a few luxuries. And on the way back from that day. I felt.
The bodies of all those thousands. Terrible.
And driving on and it was a vast cabbage patch because the Germans if they grew nothing.
And the Americans were training. In one of the fields just. Tanks so it couldn't. And sure it had very much to do.
With their anger against the Germans. They didn't want to be there.
And they would never be you know the Germans in the.
You know I could understand the attitude of the Americans
and I could also understand the attitude of the Germans because they wanted to rebuild no doubt.
But these people who considered themselves the most superior of all human.
Was ground under the heels of foreigners and like one man who said we are paying a price for something.
We didn't contribute to the bat. I knew. That. The Germans knew all about the concentration camps.
And it was easier to go to Hitler. Than to. So now. And I thought.
These bastards have given us to world almost And this last war has taken. Fifty thousand Australian. Anyhow.
That was that it was a time of bitterness. It was not a time of reconciliation and I can tell you.
I thought our plan at least. We stayed in Paris for a while and I told you about it and so then we sort of put the.
Ferry and go back to London.
So we put the car on the ferry back to London
and I have to say that going back to London boys you know where I like going home.
I've been away for so long and not thinking some languages. I had a fair bit of.
And then I'd picked up a bit of detail.
But what I mean is it was nice to go to a place where I could communicate with anyone at all or went back to London.
And I had some.
I had more money than most of the delegates I mean they're just great to get the votes no doubt about that
and I had enough money to stay in a very comfortable hotel. In Bloomsbury. Have are told you this.
You mentioned this in the last tape because you were helping other people who had any money.
Yes and I was lending money to these delegates you know but those days London had the law and restaurants.
Did you grew up in London.
I remember them from my very as a very little girl you did you Will you could carry my first.
Well London was one of the cheapest places to live in. That's not to say that the cities in Europe. Italy was dirty.
That. But a so you know we'd all meet up in the Lions where you could get.
The worst food on earth but there was plenty of it and it was cheap half dreadful and it was dangerous.
I think I mentioned it. Was unsafe to stand still in the streets of London because a coup would immediately for you.
But I was able to go to some concerts. And the cold had not started yet. And there was.
I'm not sure if this is correct but it was the friendships.
Of England and the Soviet Union and Festival Hall had just been completed and. They brought a surprise.
From what forces Soviet Union and that was the first concert are going to land. I was very impressed.
Because people there were far more relaxed with people who came from the Eastern European bloc than we were here in
Australia. And I think we turned off. At this point to come back and I came back. Which was a very big.
It had no comfort that I went over on. But when I arrived and came into Sydney.
I had a couple of to die in a night in Melbourne and then we settled up to Sydney came in through the Hades.
And I had given to me when I was in Sofia. About twelve records which I'd packed and brought all away.
I had no idea what I was. And I were. The speeches of Stalin not to be surprised that in the first place.
I was already a figure to watch. So first of all coming into Fremantle.
We had to prove to be a stand and when my mom planned up. The security sitting at the table.
Through an old stamp through. So we were all virtually with. A passport all passports were confiscated.
Was this over to like you know delicate escaped but not all that but it. Others who got the same treatment. And so.
Incidentally for ten years without a passport so were the others. And that was the very.
It was it was the cold war had started to see for Australia. Before England why things were more relaxed in England.
People welcomed others who came in from the Eastern Bloc. But not so not. And we Americans and the Americans.
Ahead on American Committee when people like Howard.
Bell for a huge ropes were all called up Milan were all called aft before the American Committee
and many were deported. Many were deported. Anyhow my passport was taken from me and I came in.
And they were the security cops on the office where customs were going through my suitcase
and I confiscated all is records. Starlin speeches in Russian. I didn't even know what was on the records.
There were also a couple of pool rooms they were taken to the bigger ones he was a red aspirant they were concerned.
And all the beautiful books that I had given to me for instance a very beautiful one given to me have certain graphs of
interest and after a few of these things and I thought well how my going to get them back.
I became very involved in the peace movement and then finally I.
I had a note from security telling me if I wanted I could go pick up those things at number forty Market Street was the
Communist Party headquarters. So there were always.
There were a couple of people whom I knew in the peace movement who spoke Russian. And I think that was Betty block.
And Peter block but I'm quite sure they certainly spoke Polish spoken a bit of Russian
and Jack Black who had a lot of Russian so I said Would you like to face it must have been a terribly a terrible shock
and a rude awakening after this extraordinary nine months that you've had to come back to Australia must have felt like
he was going backwards or something when he came back he says quote right.
I felt I was going into an extremely backward country because before I went to Bama Communist Party was introduced into
Parliament and the Campaign to Prevent the banning of the party.
I had started and it was taken before the High Court eventually
but it was in the leadership against this lack of what was taking away the rights of the citizens
and of course as much written about his particular role in that great campaign and it was when I was in.
In the month of September or October Adventists and Vienna several times on the trip passing through lack
and that we were waiting for the results to come through.
And finally they came through and said the referendum was lost.
And although the referendum was lost didn't make any difference if you were involved in the peace movement we were
going to have peace with anybody that was yet to just have peace with the Queen and all their followers you know.
I tell you it was a terrible time.
And too little is written about the Cold War in Australia far too little people lost their jobs.
Scientists had to get out of the country. And transponder jobs overseas in Britain.
All kinds of people were losing their jobs more so. Among the professions within the profession.
I mean seizing many had to go and work on the wharf so they could pick up a job.
So too little has been written about that terrible. And I'm reminded of it very much.
Now since the Howard Government came to power. Very much. Mainly because of the rise for instance of the. Group.
And Howard Latins to put it. Said to me a lot of many things that brought back.
The situation in pre-war Germany and our saw that. Here recently. Could easily happen.
And someone said to me or face aren't you being extreme and I don't think being extreme at all. Could have just moved.
Before I went away I left working for David. Making the tresses. The.
And the foreman said Well I hope you have wonderful time come back we'll see you in so many months.
So when I came back I went up from and he said I'm sorry faith but. I'm not permitted to employ you. What did you do.
And so I got it. In and I have a place. William Street. I think it was a forgotten.
I've got to really brush my memory happen that. But then I came back and got very involved in the peace movement.
And the peace movement was something that if you didn't have got to didn't get involved in it because you could lose
your job. But the terror of strength within that movement was the street.
And she couldn't care less what people said about her didn't worry.
She'd if she believed in something she went to and nothing would stop it
and she believed we had to build a strong movement to break the barriers that divided between the Eastern European
people and the West. When did you first meet Jesse ST Was it after you came back you know I met her before I went away.
Because I remember seeing her when I was in London. I met her in one hundred forty nine in Melbourne.
Can you describe your first impression. Well I did of her for you. Of course.
And during the you know I shouldn't say I made her. I actually made her. During her came.
Pain to stand for a federal seat the seat of what was known as what I think of all clues
and what it took very very early in.
And she almost Guardian as an independent and I can recall either I will leave all the most.
That I can check that are helping to letterbox out in that area for her. And then I made.
When she founded together with other women the United Association of Women and she said I should go in
and you know that I should be around with progressive women and. These women were no ordinary people.
They were all middle class upper middle class came to the meetings wrapped in full. And pearls.
But they knew what feminism was about. And what their rights workers women and they said they are. And they surrounded.
And supported.
And I knew about this and if I wasn't actually going to one of their meetings at some time or other I just knew.
But I became very much closer to. When the Dean of Canterbury visited Australia or in forty.
For the international moment convention on pace.
And Hugh that that convention would never have had the representation had it not been for J.C.
She had these contacts and like it was like I do said Xander having having lunch.
We start talking about this measure of peace and war and. And she'd say. Now look. I said to naru. Or told me.
That it is really. Just wonderful. She more than any other person on this on this earth influenced my life.
And she said to me one. I'll tell you what face. If one puts their mind to what they want. Well get it.
And she was thinking of preventing another world war and more of feeding hungry people.
And more doing things the best women's rights. So I but I better come back when you came back.
Yes
when you came back she must have been very fascinated about how she was overseas it was already overseas because
when I was in London I was seeing. And she was coming and going to Europe. But when I came back.
I was to be what was no carnival for peace.
I think kind of off piece of just forgotten what that title was but it was being organized by left wing.
And the Communist Party and I couldn't get a place in Sydney to hold it. And that was overseas delegations coming.
And those. It's great embarrassment because nobody no council would permit this festival to be held in the area.
I mean believable. There was only one who the peace movement could raid in the whole of Sydney and that was St.
And there was a Church same Thomases church in North Sydney. That permitted meetings to be held.
And I think another Unitarian Church in Sydney had a little. But you couldn't.
Like the town or anything like that heard of anybody involved in the peace movement
and mediately suspected of being a member of the Communist Party. Yes absolutely.
You didn't have to have a card to Brendan.
And we were told all of those raids working in the movement should be driven underground. Driven out of the country.
No well. Others were involved in the peace movement because the devastation in Europe.
I couldn't bloody well what happened to me and I was determined to go out
and regrettably I didn't have we didn't have video of course no television but I did my best to describe.
What I was sore into Europe the devastation of the great city. But when I arrived back Iraq.
Back when Sydney was preparing for this carnival.
And I think I came back in the month of the end of January and the carnival was to be fifty fifty two. Yes.
And the only council that would permit the festival to get it in was failed so everyone had to get out of city
and go all the way to face field to hold the carnival unbelievable. Truly it was dreadful.
And we got there because they had.
And what what the current of all who was at the carnival
and what happened you know it's all kind of all had people from different countries.
Some people from the Eastern Bloc who were able to get in and a very big contingent from.
New Zealand and of course many people came into state and the book you write it was true.
First of all people brought their dances and and they were. And the artists had a very big movement for peace.
What had I to lose but not only that they were politically conscious. Very much so. And.
I had a great Arctic submission. And it was almost to see some of Australia's leading art artists contributing to the.
Exhibition.
But we couldn't hold that exhibition anywhere because all the places were banned except at the same George Street.
Now with that exception of included people like Nancy bowling and Albert and Roy Del gone S. All those people.
Yes I want to I will say this now. So I make sure that I do that.
I want to go and see Linfox he was involved in organizing the Arctic separation.
So I can remember some of the artists who contributed but they were big shots so once more for me
and we also had people I. This is it was a very important part of my life that cold or. Did some terrible things to.
So many people. And I want to remember it.